So there are some important features that we could pick
up on from the genetic code here. The first is
that some amino acids are coded by multiple codons. In
the answer to the last exercise we sort of explored
this a little bit and see that alanine is coded
by GCU, GCC, GCA, GCG. And this happens for some
of the other amino acid as well. Another feature that
some amino acids have only codon that codes for them,
for example, trip to fan, just as UGG.
Another feature is that some codons have special
functions. For example, we see 3 appear UAA,
UAG and UGA code for stop codons, there's no
amino acid and it seems to signal. The
stop for translation. And over here, we have one
codon that seems to code for an amino
acid, methionine, but it's also representative of the start.
It appears that there's a start codon. This AUG turns out to be really
important. Because this start codon is necessary
to start protein synthesis for translation. This
is the codon that tells the ribosome
where to start. Alternatively, these stop codons
are essentially signals that tell the ribosome
where to stop. So now, using the genetic
code here I want to see if you can find the start codon, the stop codon,
and the codon that codes for Alanine, or
Ala in this following mRNA sequence. There are 3
codons to choose from, AUG, GCA, and UGA.
And for each of these options' start, I
want you to pick one of these 3
check boxes that corresponds with one of these codons.
If you have trouble reading this genetic code right here, just
look in the instructor's notes. Any time you have to use
the genetic code, and I'll always give it to you, or
any question, just look in the instructor's notes, and there'll be
a link right there. You can also download it, keep it
to yourself, you can Google image search other genetic codes if
you're interested in seeing them, but go ahead and use the
information here to see if you can answer This question and
select the correct codon for start, stop, and Alanine.